le coronavirus au début quand vous en
avez entendu parler vous avez fait des
blagues d'assumer parce que bon la chine
c'est loin et puis le virus est appelé
le corona quoi sauf que là maintenant ça
vous fait plus trop marrer parce que ça
se rapproche sérieusement et que vous
lisez tout et son contraire on va faire
un peu le prix avec allez on fait le
tour du corps en un virus en quelques
questions et on va commencer par le
commencement à savoir c'est quoi
exactement le coronavirus les
coronavirus c'est une famille de virus
en forme de couronne
d'où le nom au départ ils sont présents
chez les animaux comme la chauve souris
en l'occurrence mais ils peuvent passer
chez l'homme et provoquer des atteintes
respiratoires comme en ce moment
jusqu'ici il y avait eu six types de
corona virus transmissible à l'homme
4 pas trop méchant et 2 qui a été
responsable d'épidémies comme le strass
et le maire dans les années 2000 et 2010
pourquoi on dit que c'est nouveau la
famille des coronavirus on la connaît
depuis un petit moment c'est pour ça
qu'on en parle dans des bd dans des
bouquins ou sur des étiquettes de
désinfectant mais un virus il peut pas
vivre comme ça dans la nature il a
besoin d'être à l'intérieur d'un être
vivant pour se développer
du coup ils ont la capacité d'évoluer de
muter pour s'adapter à l'espèce dans
laquelle ils squattent et ça donne une
nouvelle forme de virus comme le kobe 19
en ce moment parce que c'est ça son
petit nom par exemple là il a fallu
qu'il évolue dans un premier temps pour
pouvoir passer chez un ami faire on
parle du congo là mais on n'est pas
encore bien sûr et puis ensuite il a
fallu qu'ils s'adaptent une deuxième
fois et qu'ils évoluent pour pouvoir
passer chez l'homme donc en fait ce
virus c'est juste le petit dernier d'une
famille qui a déjà fait parler d'elle
dans le passé pourquoi il inquiète plus
que les autres en gros ce qu'on regarde
dans une épidémie c'est est ce que le
virus est contagieux et est-ce qu'il est
dangereux
là en l'occurrence on estime que le
virus est très contagieux même s'il ya
des moyens assez simples pour éviter sa
propagation
et il a un taux de létalité de 2,3 pour
cent en gros ça veut dire que pour cent
personnes atteintes par le virus
cent personnes diagnostiquées en tout
cas il y en a un peu plus de 2 qui vont
nourrir par exemple la grippe que
responsable d'à peu près dix mille morts
chaque année en france
elle a un taux de létalité 2
0,3 pour cent pour rester dans les
chiffres et si on veut comparer
l'épidémie de sras en 2003 elle avait
tué 794 personnes dans le monde
la début mars avec le colis de 19 on en
est déjà à trois niveaux
et puis surtout la raison pour laquelle
les autorités reste hyper vigilante avec
ce virus c'est que on le connaît pas si
bien que ça en vrai et puis il ya
possibilité qu'il évolue encore comment
ça se transmet c'est un virus
respiratoires donc ça se transmet par
les sécrétions respiratoires
juste ça ces sécrétions c est ce qu on
pulvérise un petit peu partout autour de
nous quand on tousse ou qu'on ait perdu
par exemple mais on a vu un virus ça a
besoin d'être à l'intérieur d'un être
vivant pour pouvoir survivre et se
multiplier à l'extérieur y survit pas
longtemps donc la conséquence de ça
c'est que pour être contaminé par le
virus
il faut être au contact direct d'une
personne atteinte
pour être très concret on estime qu'il
faut qu'une personne atteinte par le
virus vous tous où vous était revenu à
moins d'un mètre du visage pour que vous
soyez contaminés mais les postillons et
les gouttelettes de sécrétions
respiratoires
elles peuvent aussi passer de main en
genre je tousse dans la main je te serre
la main et tu peux retire avant
septembre
comment on se protège en réalité l'idée
c'est surtout de limiter la circulation
du virus
le masque par exemple c'est pour les
malades ou pour le personnel soignant
qui s'en occupe son efficacité ça n'a
pas été prouvée pour le reste de la
population générale déjà parce que
faudrait le porter tout le temps
faudrait être sûr que c'est le bon
modèle
et puis ça résout pas le problème des
mains donc les réflexes à avoir c'est
surtout ce tout c'est très drôle coude
plutôt que dans la main utiliser des
mouchoirs en papier et les jeter tout de
suite après éviter de se serrer la main
et de se faire la bise à tout bout de
champ et ça fait pas plaisir mais c'est
les consignes et puis surtout se laver
les mains régulièrement ou utiliser du
gel hydro alcoolique pour tuer le virus
qui est dessus et puis si vous revenez
d'une zone à risque et que dans les 14
jours qui suivent
vous avez des petits problèmes
respiratoires vous à décines genre
grippe etc allez pas contaminer tout le
monde dans la salle d'attenté de votre
médecin ou aux urgences appeler le 15
et ils vous diront quoi faire qu'est ce
qui se passe si on est contaminé
déjà il faut savoir qu'il ya un délai
d'incubation d'environ six jours mais ça
peut aller de deux à quatorze jours
ça veut dire que pendant ce temps là on
est porteur du virus on peut le
transmettre
mais on n'a pas encore de signes de
maladie et alors ces signes justement
c'est quoi et bah pour 80% des gens
c'est les même qu'une petit bug mais
pour d'autres ça peut aller jusqu'à des
pneumonies graves c'est-à-dire des
problèmes au niveau des poumons qui
peuvent être mortels ça ça concerne
essentiellement les personnes fragile
c'est à dire en gros les personnages et
les personnes qui sont affaiblis par une
maladie ou un problème au niveau du
système immunitaire et c'est vrai c'est
beaucoup plus rare mais ça arrive
parfois des personnes en bonne santé
par contre d'habitude ce type de virus
il est aussi dangereux pour les bébés et
les jeunes enfants mais là bizarrement
c'est pas le cas comment ça soigne et
bah y'a pas de traitement spécifique on
n'a pas de quoi tuer le virus
on soigne juste les conséquences donc en
plus de mettre les patients en isolement
pour éviter qu'ils contaminent les
autres on soigne et essentiellement les
problèmes respiratoires et on attend que
le virus meurt tout seul évidemment il
ya plein de gens dans le monde entier en
train de chercher un traitement
spécifique pour le coc vie de 19
mais même s'il ya des avants
c'est un petit peu prometteuse ça prend
du temps et pour les vaccins c'est
encore plus et vous avez sûrement
entendu parler de la chloroquine un
traitement contre le paludisme
a priori ce serait efficace contre le
coronavirus en laboratoire mais chez
l'être humain on n'a pas encore assez
d'éléments
voilà ce qu'il faut retenir sur coville
19 c'est que on peut s'en protéger avec
des gestes assez simple on sait a encore
tout sur lui mais ya pas mal de monde
qu'il tient à l'oeil
par contre il peut encore évoluer si
vous avez des questions vous pouvez
appeler le numéro vert qui a été
spécialement mis en place
11 08 100 130 000 ou aller sur le site
dédié